buongiorno allora ragazzi diciamo che
questo gioco fa per noi si chiama please
don't touch anything consigliato sulla
community disco vi farei bravi ragazzi
vi consiglia questi giochi e si tratta
di un gioco dove tu devi non delitto
carica
questo succede un casino ad esempio
soltanto qua questo qua a toccare perché
ha ritoccato da subito master e non mi
posso girare il suo il torcicollo
ah ecco son riuscito a tirarmi ok no non
toccherò niente stai tranquillo ti
preoccupare bene mi ha solo detto di non
c'è un 66 64
mi ha detto di non toccare niente finché
non torna vabbè ma è bellissimo era un
file nighter freddy's solo dove io
faccio le cose madonna il casinò non
devo toccare niente ma perché qua c'è da
immaginarsi un bottone gigante per
favore a ragazzo dovesse sapere che
sulla mia macchina ma quando l'ho presa
c'è scritto c'è un tasto sos grosso che
io non sto schiacciando perché so che
poi succede qualcosa però l'ora di
schiacciare almeno qua almeno qua
disobbedire ok
e vabbè basta cacchio di roma col parma
questo non aver scherzato pensa e si
spegne presente a ho resettato a posto a
posto di fare rete e la situazione è
salva
non ho ben capito cosa ci devo fare
quadrare dai creava diamo contro tutto
ok
masseroli schiacci successo 3 2 1 ho
fatto casino e giovanni tasto reset
serve quando vuoi tornare codice si
resetta tutto il gioco giusto quindi
torni a questo punto qua vediamo ratio
ailog mushrooms non volendo non se ne
setaccio una sega bene o un giornalino
costituito chiamo i funghi va bene devo
resettare scusate non si può resettare
certo giornalino troppo a lodi troppo al
giornale a non lo posso mettere gli ok
ok ok se le rispetta quali sono gli
achievement che devo prendere ok ok ok
capito istruzioni prendi il tuo
cacciavite prendi il tuo martello lavora
uno uguale 11 21 21 non so capendo
niente 123456 comunque si è sto capendo
niente di colori c'è scritto però sono
dei codici sicuramente per capire come
fare sta roba qua stampa lo fa sapere
roba correct questi sono tutti
indicazioni che io non so seguivano 45
ci sono
sto male mi entra
by stew drive greppi ora mr è un
capitolo il martello e non ce l'ho cosa
me ne fa
ma posso svitare qualcosa ok è questo il
pannello ho scoperto robe ecco qui bene
non ho capito bene però ha forse come
sono email
non so qual è il giro giusto però vedi
che 3700 ci sono delle cose in giro o
quindi sono delle robe che non conosco
ok
[Musica]
cosa è successo non ho capito ma se
aperto qualche aprendo cosa faccio e
partita la radio beni cos'è si è gridato
tutto a male di che dici tu trovi degli
achievement ogni volta ad armi perché
non ho fatto niente di quello che fin
qua ci siamo continua a schiacciare fine
però se continua a schiacciare lasciato
appunto per raggiungere questo qui non
posso schiacciare all'infinito se non si
blocco che valeri potente da capirlo
ragazzi fine si arriva fino al martello
ex speaker troupe sono comparsi altri
pulsanti ok se il loro personale non sto
capendo probabile l'ho fatta io sta cosa
pure di schiacciare in mezzo se sia già
mi vedo un sacco di volte
cioè se schiacciare in mezzo un sacco di
volte spuntavano si cosi nella bella
serie bacchus presto schemi 1 suzuki che
presto un cane hachiko veseli premere
tutti e io sono sicuri poterlo fare mi
conosco come persone so di poter piacere
tutte ste cose
ok e poi lo fece
grazie per l'acqua prego pregio o ce
l'hai fatta
è bene però mai viste a lei ho scoperto
che mi chiamo stelle vabbè non ho ben
capito i colori l'ordine di colori come
lo devo prendere perché questa cosa qua
e un po e delicata sta cosa non l'ho
capita spaccare di soprano
ho rotto lo schema bene doveva trovare
succedere prima o poi c'è il bello è che
va beh mi sembra un pelo e illuminati in
touch anything la bene ok se spacchi lo
schermo escono gli illuminati pro
attenzione se avessero un suggerimento
per qualcosa che posso fare dopo la
seconda chiave è ovvio che sia
provveduto a fare qua
salve sono illuminati dietro lo schermo
mi sembrava mi sembra giusto a cercola
ricetta scorese tutto questo è il tasto
reset che lo schiaccio blu
we are working va bene lo fincato lì ok
abbiamo anche gli illuminati ottimo
posso fare anche questo
eh sì cacchio ma non avevo visto proprio
ma ci sono una cosa ma che poi tu sono
un pirla 312 qua sono il contrario sono
io questo iole gen questo 3 1 2 2 1 3 2
2 1 3 per forza non avevo altri amen
cosa è così sono raga vi sembra un po
esagerato se possiamo cosa qua c'è
qualcosa di reale di tutto poi non lo so
non lo si va bene ok mi sembra un po
esagerata tutta sta roba però ragazzi ci
sono un miliardo di indizi su stappare
non lo sapevo forse sta cercando di
comunicarmi qualcosa con lettere
dell'alfabeto può essere chiudiamo
decifri it is completely meaningless
significa che non serve un cap quello
che ho appena fatto grazie gioco gentile
dopo due ore che sono stato qua
decifrare non servito un capito che
grazie molto gentile veramente non so
come ringraziarvi e quindi raga io credo
di fermarmi qua anche perché c'è un
sacco di roba ma non saprei veramente
dovrà che parte fare lì perché certe è
veramente se non sai è veramente
difficilissimo ha lasciato
merate strane ci sono veramente è da
interpretare in un miliardo di modi sto
gioco cosa che ragazzi si lasciano
questo è un mi piace anche a risorsa
questa trascrizione fatemi sapere se
volete un altro episodio dove magari li
data anche qualche suggerimento su come
andare avanti oggi non fate 1234567
hanning ha perciò non anche qua sotto
vediamo qui fatemi sapere se avete altro
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video è la ragazza
[Musica]
ma